oh look at those Smiles family is so
important to me Tia Mowry reunites with
Corey Hardrick for a family Christmas
celebration after announcing in October
that they were calling it quits after 14
years of marriage on Instagram Tia
shares a carousel of pics showing off
her holiday weekend with Corey and their
two kids Cree 11 and Cairo four making
it clear that their children's happiness
is their highest priority how are the
little ones holding up they are doing
amazing they're also happy and that
means the world to me my children in the
photos you see Tia and Corey embracing
their kids with hugs and kisses while
also making room for funny poses like
this fun shot of their son Cree making a
silly face as his mom plants a big
smooch on his cheek the actress
captioned the snapshots quote family
will always be family Merry Christmas
from our family to yours you know I'm
all about inspiring and encouraging
um and I mean the DMS that I have gotten
from so many women that are going
through the same thing and just saying
how they admire my courage and my
strength it I mean it has just been
I feel so blessed
Corey also shared the family Christmas
photos on his Instagram simply
captioning a quote Merry Christmas with
a Christmas tree and black card Emoji in
November Tia stopped by the Today's Show
and revealed when she knew it was time
to step away from her marriage I knew
when I really started to focus on my
happiness there was this sadness
um and I knew that life is short
um I had actually you know lost my
grandmother we had lost Elena Housley
and both of them at the same time it
there was just an aha moment in me where
I said you know what you need to tap in
see what's really going on with your
happiness life is short let's go let's
start working on you and really focusing
on what really really matters here which
is at the end of the day your peace your
joy and your happiness Tia's twin sister
Tamara Mowry sat down with ET in
November and shared how her sis is
living as her true self now I told her I
said Tia I'm looking on your Instagram
this is the happiest you have ever been
in a long time you are glowing and I
said you look different but in a you
know a very positive way it's not like
oh she looked different no it's like oh
my gosh you look beautiful and and I
think it's because no not I think I know
it's because she is living her authentic
true
um self so what's an expertia she tells
E.T more realness authenticity it it's
very magical when you are living in your
truth and your honesty I feel like
amazing wonderful things happen and so I
just want to encourage you know all the
women out there to live in their truth
and to live in their authenticity and we
got you you know what I mean we're all
in this together it's about a community
and supporting each other and
encouraging each other and inspiring
each other and I mean there's so many
great things that are happening in my
life and I just feel so grateful
um and blessed
[Music]
foreign